[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya une belle introduction juste
avant vous avez remarqué ça chauffe je
vais pas revenir sur les causes le fait
est que on voit donc que les
spécialistes du climat nous nous nous
montre que la température augmente
et puis que ça va pas forcément
s'arranger dans les années qui viennent
à des pronostics iront jusqu'à + 6
degrés à l'horizon 2100 alors pourtant
on pourra pas vraiment dire qu'on savait
pas il ya donc dans les années 1800 et
quelques joseph fourier il avait déjà
bien en évidence la notion d'effet de
serre et puis arrêt du specta après il
dit la génération de carbone anthropique
va faire augmenter la température donc
ça c'était déjà il ya fort longtemps et
il a fallu attendre 200 ans pour que
collectivement on se préoccupe de cette
question et quand on organise un petit
peu de comment on allait gérer ce
problème climatique
et ça c'était il ya trente ans et puis
aujourd'hui
finalement qu'est ce qui a bougé les
jeunes essaie de remobiliser sur ces
questions mais on n'a pas encore
complètement alors je vais essayer de
repartir un petit peu sur cet ep terre
parce qu'on en entend beaucoup parler
mais peut-être ça vaut cool de reprendre
trois minutes pour essayer de comprendre
comment ça marche alors les gaz à effet
de serre le premier d'entre eux c'est
l'eau ensuite il ya le dioxyde de
carbone le méthane y en a un certain
nombre d'autres comme ça et ça nous fait
comme une couverture au dessus de la
planète et cette couverture finalement
elle est vachement bien sinon la terre
elle serait pas habitable sans les
effets de serre on serait aux alentours
de moins 20 degrés grâce à l'effet de
serre on a une planète qui est venu
habitable le problème c'est que on a
dégagé un certain nombre de gaz ces deux
dernières décennies qui ont modifié
cette couche là et petit à petit
du coup on a eu une élévation des
températures aujourd'hui on voit que ça
pose un certain nombre de problèmes
alors ses effets de serre donc je vous l
ai dit c'est notamment le dioxyde de
carbone alors le carbone si on fait un
petit peu le bilan carbone
au niveau de notre système où est-ce
qu'on en trouve on en trouve on va dire
sous quatre formes dans les océans
ça peut être solubilité dans l'eau sous
forme de sédiment on en trouve en
souterrain sous forme de charbon de
pétrole de gaz
on en trouve sur la terre dans la roche
dans nos forêts dans le tous les
systèmes animaux vivants et puis on en
trouve dans l'atmosphère le problème
c'est que ces dernières décennies on a
pas mal déstabiliser tout ça si je
reviens sur le carbone terrestre
lui il est l équilibre quand on
considère une forêt
cette forêt elle est l équilibre quand
on dit la masoni c'est le poumon de la
planète la base aunis et une grande
masse de carbone qui est stockée sous
forme solide sur la terre mais ça stocks
plus beaucoup la possible de la capacité
d'absorption de nouveaux carbone par
l'amazonie est relativement faible
par contre ce grand stock là bas alors
pourquoi c'est stable c'est parce que en
gros l'arbre il est pendant pendant sa
jeunesse il va capter du carbone par la
photosynthèse ce carbone va s'accumuler
dans la dans la plante la plantera
continuent leur dire mais tout être
vivant à une fin de vie est en fin de
vie la plante va mourir l'arbre va
tomber va être dégradée par les micro
organismes qui vont relâcher du co2 et
donc on est sur un système fermé en est
à l'équilibré
alors maintenant si je regarde un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
décennies ben on a énormément puiser sur
les stocks de carbone qui étaient
stockés sur la planète d'abord sur le
carbone souterrain le charbon le pétrole
le gaz et puis sous forme de
déforestation et à une grande quantité
de végétal qui a été remise dans
l'atmosphère et puis on a construit on a
construit en utilisant des procédés qui
dégageait du ce et du dioxyde de carbone
aussi on à déforester notamment pour
faire de l'agriculture parce qu'il y
avait tout un tas de changement des
usages des terres si on fait le bilan
aujourd'hui on a à peu près 80 % de ses
émissions qui issue donc de ce qu'on a
déstocké du souterrain le pétrole le gaz
et le charbon 15% pour la déforestation
et 5% pour le ciment et ça on est
souvent au moins au courant pourquoi
pour le suivant
parce que la fabrication du ciment
intrinsèquement sais je prends du
calcaire caco3 et je vais supprimer à
co2 que je vais envoyer dans
l'atmosphère pour garder du cio et du
coup le ciment à lui tout seul
représente 5 % des émissions de gaz à
effet serre maintenant si on veut aller
à la rencontre de ce processus qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour re stocker du
carbone
alors on a vu que nos océans on n'y est
pour rien mais ils ont retoqué mais
s'est imposé d'un certain nombre de
problèmes d'acidification continue et
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
finalement ne peut agir pas sur grand
chose mais on peut agir sur les forêts
on en a beaucoup parlé on peut agir sur
les forêts mais je vous ai dit c'est un
cycle fermé donc si on veut pouvoir agir
il va falloir qu'on sorte du bois mais
qu'on le laisse pas périr on va stocker
se boit on va le sortir
le fait de sortir ce bois va laisser de
la place pour de nouveaux arbres pour
grandir qui eux vont stocker du carbone
et se voit que j'ai sorti si je veux le
stocker il faut que le stock le plus
durablement possible
donc je vais m'en servir une tonne un
mètre cube de carbone c'est une tonne de
co2 qui est ok donc utilisa en bois un
produit en bois j'ai des coûts de
fabrication des coûts énergétiques de
fabrication mais j'ai surtout un très
gros stockage et le deuxième un effet
c'est que si j'avais pas utiliser la par
exemple sept palettes en bois et que
j'avais pris un produit d'origine
plastique par exemple et j'aurais eu là
d'autres coûts c'est à dire des coûts
pétroliers d'aller l'extraire du carbone
et des coûts énergétiques
je les prie sur cet exemple je peux le
prendre sur un autre exemple ou là ça va
pas être dans la composition la chute
sur une fenêtre en aluminium la fenêtre
en ml miremont on a des coûts
énergétiques de production qui sont
énormes
donc avec le bois en gagnent deux fois
et peut-être qu'on gagne trois fois
parce qu'en fait si on peut se
substituer à d'autres matériaux
c'est ça qu'on évite c'est tout les
dégâts associés que ce soit
l'exploitation pétrolière où que ce soit
l'exploitation du calcaire pour
fabriquer du ciment ou les minerais pour
faire de l'aluminium ou de l'acier ça de
toute façon des impacts colossaux d'un
point de vue environnement
un dernier point on va être gagnant sur
le bois ça va être la fin de vie du
produit en fin de vie le bois il est
recyclable c'est à dire que la palette
on va pouvoir en faire là-bas note
particules par exemple en la mettant en
copeaux on va pouvoir faire une
valorisation énergétique c'est
l'essentiel de la valorisation
aujourd'hui qui est fait c'est à dire
qu'on va pouvoir alimenter des centrales
thermiques qui vont produire de
l'énergie
et puis si par hasard on la perd dans la
nature
elle est biodégradable et ça il ya quand
même un enjeu énorme quand on voit la
problématique du plastique qui est en
train d'envahir nos océans ou même si
vous vous baladez dans l'arrière-pays
régulièrement on tombe sur des vieux
objets qui ont été oubliés il ya
peut-être fort longtemps mais qui sont
toujours là alors il faut quand même se
poser la question il n'y a pas un risque
sur nos forêts si on commence à vouloir
tout faire en bois est ce que est ce que
c est ce que c'est réellement viable
alors la forêt je voulais dire le bois
c'est un matériau renouvelable
renouvelables ça veut dire que quand je
vais prélever du bois en fait je vais
laisser de la place où il ya du nouveau
bois qui va pouvoir se fabriquer pour ça
faut que ce soient gérées durablement
c'est le cadre de la forêt française est
parce que la forêt et gérées durablement
on va avoir une croissance et si je
prends le cas de la forêt française
c'est le cas de l'ensemble des forêts
européennes d'ailleurs aussi on est en
croissance c'est à dire que depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années on n'utilise
pas tout le bois qui chaque année est
fabriqué par la forêt on en utilise un
peu plus de la moitié mais pas plus ça
veut dire qu'on a encore une marge
donc on a un stock de bois qui
augmentent en europe aujourd'hui et dans
lequel on peut aller puiser cette forêt
elle nous apporte du bois mais nous
apporte beaucoup plus elle nous apporte
une grande richesse de biodiversité
qu'elle permet d'héberger un certain
nombre d'espèces c'est un filtre pour
les poussières elle des rôles dans
l'épuration de l'eau
elle a de nombreux atouts comme ça et la
forêt si on veut la préserver
finalement les usages du bois je vous ai
parlé jusqu'à maintenant c'est peut-être
là quels enjeux majeurs les usages du
bois y donne de la valeur à la forêt
aujourd'hui on l'a vu
au brésil on le voit un petit peu
partout il ya de nombreux conflits sur
les usages des terres avec cet espace là
est ce que je dois faire un centre
commercial
est ce que je dois faire un parc
d'attraction est ce que je dois faire de
l'agriculture pour faire de l'élevage
si j'ai le choix entre une vrai qu'il
n'a pas de valeur et cet usage le choix
est compliquée et économiquement
si le bois prend sa juste valeur alors
j'ai intérêt à investir dans de la forêt
à préserver de la forêt notamment en
amazonie
alors dans la vie donc un certain nombre
d'atouts mais est-ce qu'on peut tout
faire avec le bois est ce que réellement
le bois peut se substituer à l'ensemble
des matériaux qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
alors quand on dit le bois c'est souvent
les bois on et diversité d'espèces en
france et dans le monde qui est qui est
phénoménal et donc on tâte toute une
diversité de produits associés mais même
en restant dans des cas simples vous
voyez que le bois il a évidemment des
propriétés de structure parce que c'est
pour ça qu'il a été fait break fabriqués
par là bas mais il a des propriétés
hygroscopique qui font qu'il est un bon
régulateur climatique dans l'habitat il
a des bonnes propriétés par exemple pour
faire du papier il a des propriétés
gustatives qui sont en train très
intéressante pour faire du vin etc
donc on a toute une palette d usage
maintenant si je reviens à ma question
de départ qui est l'enjeu d'utiliser du
bois pour stocker du carbone l'a
finalement on se rende compte qui est
important c'est trouver des usages où on
va voir des temps de stockage très long
et sur des très gros volumes et ça on va
le trouver dans la construction bois
contraire en bois on sait faire on sait
faire depuis longtemps
c'est le matériau qu'on a toujours
utilisé pour faire votre habitat et
notre patrimoine regorge de structures
de ce type
c'est exceptionnel pourtant dans ce dans
ce contexte là on a utilisé presque tout
le temps des matériaux massif assez peu
transformés on a mis en oeuvre des
poutres qu'on a taillé dans des hard on
appris des blocs de bois dans les arbres
et dans ce cadre là le bois est
résistant légers faciles à transformer
la seule limite bien sûr c'est la taille
des arbres on a fait évoluer nos
savoir-faire amis de la technique on a
mis du progrès pour faire une vraie
révolution
la construction bois c'est révolutionner
ces dernières années c'est ces vingt
dernières années
lc révolutionner en apportant des
nouveaux produits on a fait les
processus d'aboutage de reconstitution
de collage de croiser âge on a fait les
plis croiser des plis cloud et on a
offert aux ingénieurs structure
différents types de produits pour
réaliser des ouvrages tout ça incluant
énormément de bois aujourd'hui on sait
faire des structures avec des très
grands volumes
c'est faire des parkings des parkings
avions par exemple avec des trucs
bâtiments qui font jusqu'à 100 mètres de
longueur 12 mètres de hauteur et surtout
avec des poutres qui font deux mètres de
haut avec des longueurs de 34 m ça c'est
des choses qu'on sait faire aujourd'hui
et par exemple ici on stocke 380 tonnes
de co2 pour faire un hangar comme ça
c'est faire aussi d'écran de portée pour
faire des stades on peut pas avoir pour
respecter la fonction des piliers au
milieu c'est pas possible donc il faut
qu'on ait des très grande portée jusqu'à
80 m de portée par exemple pour ce stade
on vient préfabriqué des treillis comme
le fait la filière métallique et puis on
va assembler sur site pour faire la
charpente de ce bâtiment là on va garder
le métal uniquement où on a besoin juste
dans les zones d'assemblage et dans
certains aujourd'hui construire en bois
permet une grande liberté de forme on
peut faire des formes complètement libre
et architectes savent imaginer des
choses incroyables et en bois on arrive
à y répondre aujourd'hui on peut faire
des formes de récits comme des textiles
dans les files sont et poutres et petits
éléments de bois convient tisser et
qu'on vient poser sur les bâtiments pour
faire des formes complètement libre
complètement incurvé de ce type
et puis on sait aussi faire des supports
de verrières par exemple c'est dans ces
cas là qu'il faut des éléments
extrêmement raide on peut pas tolérer
que des formations on doit résister au
vent et on arrive avec des poutres comme
ça on l'a mais les feuilleter un mettre
en place du bois dans ces structures à
et puis on sait que le bois il travaille
avec l'eau on sait qui va évoluer dans
son comportement et sa aujourd'hui on le
connais suffisamment bien pour faire des
centres aquatiques des piscines et
patinoires et puis on va le mettre aussi
dans des environnements un petit peu
plus compliqué si par exemple au canada
pour faire le tablier d'un pont on a mis
en place des poutres en bois pour
arriver à faire ce point
mais là où le secteur va être
déterminant c'est qu'entre vouloir
humaniser on va faire des écoles demain
qui seront plus évolutive plus facile à
concevoir en faisant des modules
préfabriqués qu'on va mettre en place
sur site un peu comme des lego et ça va
permettre de faire facilement une
surélévation une extension pour faire
une classe de plus inclure un élément
pour un médecin par exemple ce genre de
choses et là où on va être déterminant
nous en tant que client que maître
d'ouvragé
ça va être dans l'habitat c'est là que
l'image du bois va être important c'est
aujourd'hui faire d habitat contemporain
avec par exemple a pas des chalets et
maisons qui ont un style complètement
moderne
cette maison est complètement en bois
les planches et les murs les plafonds
tout est en bois et là où on va surtout
gagner c'est dans le résidentiel
collectif c'est pour faire des bâtiments
de grande envergure
par exemple un bâtiment ici de 18
niveaux qui est fait uniquement avec
neuf personnes sur site entièrement
préfabriqués et on vient amener les
éléments sur les chantiers en a pas ici
quasiment sur le chantier on vient lever
les éléments les mettre en place et on
passe à l'étape suivant ce bâtiment et
ferrand deux mois c'est trois fois moins
que pour faire le même en béton c'est le
choix de cette rapidité qui a été fait
pour le village olympique à france 2024
cette rapidité de chantier on va avoir
40 ouvrages à construire en moins de
quatre ans est la seule alternative
possible c'est de le faire en bois là où
on va aussi faire évoluer la filière
c'est d'aller faire des bâtiments de
plus en plus haut il ya dix ans on
faisait les bâtiments jusqu'à à peu près
30 mètres de hauteur
aujourd'hui on a à peu près presque
triplé ont fait des bâtiments à 80 90
mètres de hauteur
et demain on a des projets avec des
tours des gratte ciel jusqu'à 350 m on
doit intensifier notre culture
d'utiliser du bois dans différents en
différents secteurs mais surtout dans le
bâtiment on doit accentuer notre culture
scientifique
on doit faire de la formation envers les
jeunes parce que l'avenir il est plus
dans nos carrières
il est vraiment dans nos forêts 0
[Applaudissements]